[Musik]
genannt und willkommen zu einem kurzen
nachrichten überblick in der
halbzeitpause die gestiegenen preise
treffen geringverdiener besonders hart
viele drohen in armut abzurutschen sagen
diakonie und das institut für
wirtschaftsforschung und fordern
konsequenzen
mindestens 100 euro pro monat für
besonders bedürftige markus gross hat
details
fast 2000 personen versorgen die
ehrenamtlichen mitarbeiter der
finsterwalder tafel im monat mit
lebensmitteln die steigenden preise für
gas mobilität und nahrungsmittel werden
für viele zunehmend zum problem
eine aktuelle studie im auftrag der
diakonie kommt zu dem ergebnis
preissteigerung treffen besonders
einkommensschwache der vorschlag jeder
bedürftige erwachsene sollte monatlich
100 euro für ein halbes jahr zusätzlich
zu seinen sozialleistungen bekommen
zielgenau und einige effektive
unterstützung der ärmsten unserer
gesellschaft werden deshalb spätestens
im herbst viele menschen vor einer
bitteren alternative stehen entweder
weniger zu essen oder eben tatsächlich
zu frieren kosten würde der vorschlag
5,4 milliarden euro das sei gut
investiertes geld mahnt das deutsche
institut für wirtschaftsforschung die
politik müsse schnell handeln es ist
nicht nur ein problem in den betroffenen
menschen sondern auch
gesamtgesellschaftlich
gesamtwirtschaftlich ein zunehmendes
großes problem für deutschland weil es
die soziale polarisierung auf die
sozialen konflikte verschärft jeder
dritte hat keiner staates und
preissteigerung abzufangen schnell mehr
geld im geldbeutel für viele wäre dass
die hilfe in der not
im bereich verkehr und bei den gebäuden
wurden die klimaziele im vergangenen
jahr nicht erreicht deswegen mussten die
zuständigen ministerien heute
sofortprogramme vorlegen die direkt
kritisiert wurden fdp verkehrsminister
wissing nehme den klimaschutz nicht
ernst genug spd bauministerin geiwitz
plane zu langfristig simon pfanzelt
berichtet
eigentlich wollte das kabinett heute ein
gemeinsames klimaschutz sofortprogramm
präsentieren aber es gab zu viel streit
zwischen den ministerien
deshalb stellten die bau ministerin und
der verkehrsminister jeweils eigene
programme vor in getrennten
pressekonferenzen
im gebäudesektor soll neue fördergelder
für sanierungen kommen die 400.000 neuen
wohnungen die sich die bundesregierung
vorgenommen hat sollen klimafreundlich
gebaut werden ab 2024 soll es keine
neuen reinen gasheizungen mehr geben
angesichts des furchtbaren krieges den
russland in der ukraine führt ist auch
klar wir müssen natürlich auch anders
heizen als nur mit erdgas auch beim
verkehr ist der nachholbedarf groß die
ladeinfrastruktur soll ausgebaut werden
genauso wie das radwegenetz die qualität
des öffentlichen nahverkehrs soll
verbessert werden ein tempolimit ist
weiterhin nicht vorgesehen ich muss
abwägen zwischen der schnellen
erreichung von klimaschutzzielen
einerseits und den
mobilitätsanforderungen und auch der
akzeptanz der gesellschaft für maßnahmen
andererseits manchen ist das zu wenig
wir haben keine zeit mehr denn in der
tat brauchen wir dringend mehr
klimaschutz maßnahmen in allen sektoren
das gemeinsame konzept zum klimaschutz
hat die bundesregierung nun auf
september verschoben
die telefonische krankschreibung soll
wiederkommen fordern kassen ärzte und
hausärzte und auch der
gesundheitsminister ist angesichts hoher
corona zahlen dafür die ärzteverbände
wollen krankschreibungen per telefon
sogar dauerhaft festschreiben
nach viereinhalb monaten krieg in der
ukraine sieht aussenministerin baerbock
aktuell keine chance auf
friedensgespräche mit russland
verhandelt wird aber über eine
wiederaufnahme von getreide lieferungen
russische und ukrainische vertreter
trafen sich dazu in der türkei ergebnis
unklar aktuell stecken schiffe mit
millionen tonnen getreide fest
in sri lanka halten die unruhen wegen
der wirtschaftskrise an präsident
rajapaksa trat trotz ankündigungen nicht
zurück sondern floh ins ausland
zehntausende protestierten nun gegen
seinen stellvertreter premierminister
wickremesinghe und stirbt dessen
amtssitz es kam zu auseinandersetzungen
mit der polizei
jetzt geht der ausnahmezustand
zurück nach deutschland ein jahr ist das
her innerhalb weniger stunden
verwandelte die flut ein beschauliches
flusstal in ein verschlanktes
katastrophengebiet und bis heute wird
aufgearbeitet was in dieser nacht und
danach alles schief lief die
bundesregierung hat jetzt eine strategie
vorgelegt um notlagen besser bewältigen
zu können ines trams
die große flut vor einem jahr sie
offenbarte massive schwachstellen in der
katastrophenbewältigung mangelnde
koordination überforderte einsatzkräfte
chaos bei den zuständigkeiten daraus
will die bundes innenministerin nun
lehren ziehen sie will einen neustart im
bevölkerungsschutz
wir werden unser land krisenfester
machen wir werden uns besser gegen
krisen und klimafolgen wappnen dafür
werden wir vor allem besser chor linien
besser kommunizieren und besser
kooperieren mobile notfall zeltstädte
will die ministerin anschaffen alte
sirenen sollen auf vordermann gebracht
und waren apps verfeinert werden ein
bevölkerungsschutz tag soll die menschen
sensibilisieren wir wollen eine
sicherheitspartnerschaft mit den
bürgerinnen das beginnt damit dass wir
zu hören was die schutzbedürfnisse
anliegen und wünsche der bevölkerung
sind und wir wollen ihre potenzial
einbeziehen und kompetenzen stärken zu
lange haben wir uns zu sicher gefühlt in
deutschland sagt die ministerin nun will
man sich besser wappnen und aus der flut
von vor einem jahr lernen
der südwesten europas leidet unter
temperaturen von über 40 grad die
extreme hitze und dürre begünstigt
waldbrände auch an der französischen
atlantikküste
südlich von bordeaux wurden etliche
zeltplätze vorsorglich evakuiert
jetzt noch flott die lottozahlen sie
lauten 10 11 29 30 45 47 und die
superzahl 8 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lauter punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157
morgen wird's heiss details gibt's jetzt
gleich beim wetter gegen 21 uhr 50 das
heute journal wir sagen danke und
tschüss und wünschen weiter viel spaß am
fußball
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter kühle luft
erreicht uns von norden und da ist dann
eine kaltfront mit dem spiel die wird
gewitter auslösen und kommende woche
gibt es die hitzewelle und das ist mit
diesem tief verbunden das wird dann die
hitze zu uns führen aber dass erst in
der nächsten woche und wir gucken in die
nacht die kaltfront löst nach nordwesten
hin teilweise schauer aus und auch ganz
im süden gibt es schauer bei neun bis 18
grad und morgen zieht die kaltfront
rhein und im osten gibt es gewitter
können auch kräftiger ausfallen und ganz
im norden ebenfalls schauer bei höchsten
temperaturen bis 37 grad maximal im
südwesten sehr heiß ganz anders nach
norden ihr teilweise nur 18 bis 24 grad
und die nächsten tage am freitag schauer
im süden und ganz im norden bei 29 grad
und ab sonntag steigen die temperaturen
wieder über die 30 grad marke ein
schöner abend